how Millie Bobby Brown
became an actor I became an actor at the
right by age of eight I've always loved
kind of performing in whatever capacity
that was dancing singing the whole lot
and I became an actor by just
being bored on a Saturday really
it's not much else to it how does Millie
boy Brown hide her accent I don't I will
like switch in between sometimes I'll
just go straight into my American accent
which is a lot harder and I could maybe
finish the autocomplete interview like
this okay so how did Millie Bobby Brown
and Jake Bon Jovi well I don't know
how did Millie Bobby Brown and Jake Bon
Jovi that's my question oh it's meat oh
oh God that's embarrassing um how do we
meet we met on
Instagram
the old Instagram and uh we were friends
for a bit and then um
what can I say